[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dormez
oh répondez moi mon sens vous m'avez
fait peur je m'étais assoupi où sont les
autres
les hommes jouent aux cartes dans la
bibliothèque s'est entendus se disputer
tout à l'heure les femmes sont montées
se coucher se sont enfermés à double
tour
avez vous pu prévenir quelqu'un
impossible la neige a coupé la route du
col pas des dangers qu'ils viennent
c'est plus il a dit qu'il viendrait
je vous répète qu'il ne peut pas la
route est impraticable et le chasse
neige ne passera que demain matin
il viendra donc tuera tous je vous
croyais coucher je n'arrive pas à dormir
j'ai entendu un bruit sourd comme
étouffé venant du jardin j'ai regardé
par la fenêtre mais je n'ai rien vu rien
que la neige qui tombait dieu merci tu
es là j'ai entendu du bruit toi aussi
non tu devrais aller trop couché non non
je suis sûr que je ne me suis pas trompé
c'est votre imagination tu travailles
personne ne troublera votre sommeil
cette nuit tient une réunion de famille
vous avez terminé votre parti oui j'ai
battu professeur à plate couture il est
fou de rage alors toujours vos histoires
de briand qui vous tient éveillé ce ne
sont pas des histoires de brigands on
voit bien que vous n'êtes pas d'ici
c'est un malfaiteur qui a toujours tenu
parole il actu et chaque fois qu'il l'a
dit chaque fois qu'il a posé le doigt
sur une maison de ce village il
assassiné tous les occupants
pourquoi ne pas avoir prévenu la police
j'ai essayé mais nous sommes tout à fait
isolé alors votre criminel ne viendra
pas ce soir à moins qu'il ne soit déjà
là un principe est fouillé la maison de
fond en compte
je voulais dire parmi nous parmi nous on
ne vous ne pensez pas ce que vous dites
pourquoi pas après tout ça ne l'a jamais
vu personne ne sait qui il est ni d'où
il vient et pourquoi il a juré la mort
de civils
mais la police ne possède aucun indice
tu sais depuis bien longtemps
indique-t-on à qualité parmi les plus
sages habitants commandes vont devenir
d'au-delà des collines
il faut croire que ces mots contiennent
quelque chose de prophétique
ouais
il est mort monsieur monsieur c'est vous
qui avez cru pour l'enfant avait bien
dit que nous répétions mais mes vaches
vous entendu crier alors j'ai eu peur
et puis moi sort alors du noir ah bon
alors alors pourquoi faire tout ça donne
moi quand il fait si beau soleil de
l'action de la pièce se déroule en une
nuit d'hiver
dans un chat nalyse les montagnes
d'assez difficile de répéter en plein
soleil
c'est moi n y at il demandé à nos amis
de reconstituer si cette mise en scène
afin de gérer de plus près la réalité
abba profitons de cette interruption
pour faire une petite pause on cher
maître vous avez été parfait or je vous
en remercie et je bénis le ciel que ce
rôle n'est pas été encore disent aimer
parce que ça va bien aller faire mes
débuts dans la commune
permettez moi de vous dire mon cher
maître que vous êtes très très doué et
si julie à le dit vous pouvez le croire
le secrétaire perpétuelle de l'académie
française qui se prend pour un acteur
tel honneur
avant d'aller plus loin je voudrais
faire quelques remarques
si vous le permettez mon cher auteur
[Applaudissements]
voilà nous en sommes à la 30e page et la
pièce vient tout juste de commencer au
moment où j'ai dit vous dormez oui
seulement depuis aristophane au théâtre
on n'a jamais pu échapper à ce qu'on
appelle l'exposition mais ça c'est pas
une exposition c'est un vernissage
oui alors qu'est-ce que vous ne demandez
pas mon avis moi je vous le donne bien
je ne trouve pas ça folichon donné
toutes les expositions semble longue il
faut il faut tout même bien présenter
les personnages au public
si vous voulez que le public comprenne
quelque chose ou alors vous en [ __ ] et
éclaire une pièce hermétique mais ça
n'allait pas mon style et le style c'est
l'homme alors ou alors chargé à des
comédiens de jouer le rôle du coeur de
la tragédie antique
c'est à dire s'adresser directement au
public mais là messieurs vous allez voir
une pièce policière la victime
c'est le personnage qui est assis dans
ce fauteuil il ne dit rien il ne dit
rien parce qu'il est mort
le personnage qui fait aux roquettes à
côté de lui ses assassins
si on si elle avance qui est l'assassin
ya plus classe policière je ne sais pas
il y aura surtout plus de pièces
policière pour vous si moi je reprends
mon petit manuscrits sous le bras et
s'il veut le porter à d'autres comédiens
qui eux ne trouveront peut-être
folichonne quel caractère d'oublier un
petit peu trop que je suis la directrice
du théâtre que nous avons signé un
contrat tous les deux j'ai tout de même
moment à dire enfin toutes ces
discussions
que va penser notre cher max et là tu as
raison excusez moi mon cher ami je me
suis laissé emporter et je vous prie de
m'excuser mais rencontre je suis ravi
mardi
oui ok compte ils sont beaucoup plus
raide mais aussi embête un peu non mais
tandis qu'ici vous allez connaître des
moments exaltants
l'auteur va me laisser à nouveau de
retirer sa pièce la directrice va
proposer des changements qui s'avèreront
sans aucun intérêt la vedette devait
exiger d'être affichées tout seul il
mettra fin va monter la pièce à anvers
au mans pour soutenir sa toile
c'est malin le tableau idyllique vous me
mettez l'eau à la bouche
mon cher m pourquoi n'avez vous jamais
écrit pour le théâtre
après ce que je viens d'entendre là que
je me demande quand l'historien
enfin le romancier a terminé son ouvrage
il en éprouve une sorte de soulagement
mais aussi un peu de tristesse pour lui
l'aventuré terminée pour vous elle ne
fait que commencer
on sait que nous avons
académie deux ou trois auteurs
dramatiques sacd et bien nous les avions
mis environ secret parce qu'il crée des
personnages de chair et d'os
ils peuvent le voir évoluer sur les deux
scènes puis ces merveilleuses à ces
faits j'ai eu tout à fait raison de vous
demander d'assister à une répétition
comme vous avez apporté votre manuscrit
d'abord sa mère d'anne eu l'occasion de
jouer un rôle
et dieu sait comment merci mademoiselle
et puis vous m'avez fait l'honneur et la
joie de venir jusqu'à moi revanche à
manger ravi c'était bien la 3d les
choses mais oui surtout avec votre
grippe ne tranche
oui on m'a dit a pas d'âge pour avoir la
grippe m'amuser et bien écoutez écoutez
je m'en vais répondre de deux minutes
je reviens j'ai hâte de connaître la
suite
ça voulait dire le début m un port en
lourd tu veux relancer le débat sur les
expositions alors je vaux chance je vous
en prie ne laissez pas ses mots donc je
voulais dire tout à l'heure que dans
cette scène qui est bien fait bien
construite et qui a même une réelle
dimension dans quel sens l'entente u
dans le sens de la longueur naturel
vous n'avez pas recommencer 1 nous
savons tous que l'action débute vraiment
à l'entrée de guillaume nous sommes tous
d'accord sur ce point
alors on va pas recommencer je crois
tout de même qu'on pourrait couper un
peu dans le texte de caroline pas
pourquoi dans mon texte
pourquoi pas dans le tien mais ma chère
ma chance sont ils des maquis j'accepte
par avance toutes les coupures qu'on
jugera utile si elles peuvent servir la
pièce mais je ne vois vraiment pas où
tout ce que dit mon personnage est
absolument indispensable
tu trouvais pas ça folichon il n est pas
folichon non indispensables nuances et
c'est que je dis moi ça ne l'est pas
indispensable mais pas totalement ma
chérie excuse moi un état considérations
sur le mariage pastis 9 ou 10 n'a rien
compris c'est la clé du personnage un
passe-partout non plus laissez moi je ne
comprends pas enfin tout dépend de ce
que tu en feras du personnage évidemment
pourquoi être et des 2 es sur ton talent
aucun ma série nous c'est une big walls
je suis
teint que dans la première scène tu vas
être fait
merci viennent dans la première scène
joue les idiotes
alors dans ces conditions je vous
conseille de chercher une autre pour le
remplacer vous n'aurez pas de mal
il y assez de talent dans les carolines
7 avril blessé et peu voulait vraiment
bien tous les deux je vous en prie
assieds toi ma cocotte ces quelques
petites coupures sont nécessaires c'est
moi qui en déciderai en accord avec
l'auteur bien entendu j'aime entendre
cette précision
nous verrons cela plus tard l'avancé
parce que si on devait écouter tous les
bons amis qui vous suggère des coupures
il y aurait plus de pièces d'autant que
je n'ai jamais rencontré deux personnes
d'accord pour couper au même endroit
lors des répétitions de ma première
pièce tu t'en souviens que tu es déjà
cessé par proches des plages et écouter
tous les gens qui m'entouraient j'ai
coupé à droite à gauche à tort et à
travers croyez moi la pièce n'a rien à
gagner
moi non plus je veux dire qu est la
directrice non plus n'a rien amené
d'ailleurs personne n'a rien de l'année
assure tout de même
ainsi les quelques spectateurs égarés
qui sont venus ils pouvaient être les
deux bonnes heures la plupart avaient
déjà commencé leur nuit rouge est ce que
tu peux être amusant toi à la ville où
on va écouter l'exposition est longue
mais la pièce est courte
alors si nous commençons à un 9h10 pour
finir à 22h40 avec 20 minutes d'entracte
les spectateurs n'auront pas pour leur
argent mais moi je ne tiens pas du tout
mais lors du tout a volé ma clientèle
j'aime quand tu vole au secours d'un
clientèle l'armée va te dire que c'est
idiot de merde pourquoi ça il vaut quand
même mieux que le public soit passionné
pendant une heure et demie que de
s'embêter pendant trois heures et oui
mais le malheur avec toi c'est qu'il
n'est pas le choix du public ne vous
discutez pas et revenons à la pièce ah
bah justement voici mais reprenons la
lecture
je continue à lire l'euro je n'osais pas
vous demander à metteur en scène le vert
toutes les audaces donc ça un peu plus
musclée que tout à l'heure à l'étude
julien mazy
ma vie excuse moi de les mettre en scène
je suis le même moteur tu connais quand
j'écris un texte humain a priori parce
que je souhaite un jour on l'entendent
en place il faut encore tiens je ne sais
vraiment pas pourquoi j'ai écrit la fin
de la phrase parce que pour un tendre
tiens acheteurs c'était pas la peine que
j'écrivais
alors j'aimerais l'entendre si c'est
possible c'est un média tout de même
tient une réunion de famille si c'est
possible
tient une réunion de fin la pièce est
heureuse et bonne raison qu'il allait
recommencer tient une réunion de famille
vous avez terminé votre parti oui j'ai
battu le professeur à perdre couture et
les foudres ah non non non non non c'est
alors le toujours vos histoires de
brigands qui vous tiennent éveillé
oh bon sang on m'avait fait peur c'est à
vous m c'est un oui au pardon toujours
en histoire de brigands qui vient c'est
la tristesse rire ça c'est à dire alors
on dort et après vous après je me fais
répéter alors toujours vos histoires de
brigands qui vous tient éveillé ce ne
seront pas des histoires de brigands on
voit bien ce mot il voit pas lui ne
voulait pas d'ici c'est un malfaiteur
qui est toujours tenu parole et a tué
chaque fois qu'il l'a dit
chaque fois qu'il a posé le doigt sur
une maison de ce village je mets le
doigt la mise en scène respecté par
chaque fois qu'il a posé le doigt sur
ces maisons
tu peux pas faire on finit la police en
challenge qu'est ce que tu dis mais
pourquoi ne pas avoir prévenu la police
j'ai essayé mais nous sommes tout à fait
isolé alors votre criminel ne viendra
pas ce soir à moi qu'il se soit déjà là
après si j'ai fouillé la maison de faux
tampon ce cerveau à boire a donc fait
international eri entre parenthèses
n'oubliez pas à oui oui on est oui en
effet je savante abois ne rabats nos
bonnes et je voulais dire parmi nous
annonce qu'on vend par parmi nous mais
vous ne pensez pas ce que vous dit
pourquoi pas après tout personne ne l'a
jamais vu personne ne sait qui il est ni
d'où il vient ni pourquoi il a juré la
mort de ce fromage pour villa
[Rires]
mais la police ne possède aucun indice
s'est depuis bien longtemps un dicton
accrédités parmi les plus sages
habitants que rien ils vont le devenir
de l'année colline pourquoi que ces mots
contiennent quelque chose de prophétique
alors là le critt je ne vais pas crier
fort qu'on ne pas appeler liette
ne bougez pas il est mort il faut
laisser les choses en état pour la
police demain matin vous voyez il avait
raison l'assassin est parmi nous et il
n'a pas fini de tuer j'en suis sûr oh
mon dieu
personne n'a rien vu moi moi j'ai j'ai
senti quelque chose
une présence invisible impalpable et
j'ai entendu des bruits de pas sur le
tapis c'est un filtre le tapis ce
partage du sud
j'ai entendu des bruits bon j'ai entendu
des bruits de pas sur le tapis pour ce
coup je me trouvais mal vous y croyez
maintenant à notre histoire de
croquemitaine oui oui je suis médium et
depuis un moment d'étranges visions
voltigent autour de moi comme des ombres
il n'y a rien dans tout cela de
surnaturel vous avez beaucoup bu et cela
excite votre imagination
c'est moi c'est moi qui dis non c'est
pas ça s'il dépasse iphone c'est moi je
braque inventé cette histoire de vie la
chaume ou refaire le mot body la raison
il a raison protéger nous il existe dans
cette caisse quelque chose de maléfique
je vais chercher le professeur ne nous
laissez pas seul je ne serai pas long
mais alors stop c'est pas possible alors
il tout il faudra non seulement possible
mais nous sommes au coeur de l'action il
faudra bien sentir monter l'angoissé la
présence du professeur bibliothèque ce
personnage que le public ne verra jamais
au lieu de rassurer doit amener le
spectateur jusqu'au frissons voilà et
parce que sais je sais ce que j'ai senti
en écrivant mais c'est parce que les
jantes en le voyant
oui on pourrait me trois semaines de
répétitions trois semaines seulement
alors tu vois ça alors ça encore est ce
que ça veut dire monsieur messer buron
vient d'arriver coupe du roi ici il n'ya
qu'en mai mais je ne m'attendais à cette
heure on a quelques vérités mais les 3r
monsieur vous à regarder à bastille m'a
dit qu'il avait rendez vous avec
monsieur oui mais à 5 heures je lui ai
dit vous m'aviez prévenu mais que vous
ne l'attendiez pas si tôt at il répondu
il m'a dit qu'il y avait contre autre
ordre ben c'est ce qu'il a dit oui
veut-elle pas venir à 5 heures on n'a
pas envie qu'ils auraient pu prévenir
bon nom de couteau dit il que me suis
occupé je suis occupé soit en train de
lire
rôle dans une pièce et je lancerai donné
que je le pourrai bien monsieur de
installez le dans le petit salon un
millier t'installer monsieur il est allé
tout seul
il est vrai qu'il connaît le chemin
c'est la cinquième visite protocolaire
il me rend bureau à l'académie française
on aura tout vu toto mary épouse encore
entre dit nous nous passons dans trois
semaines on répète oui ou non
excusez-moi mètres mais j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'on avance dans le 2 vous
avez vous intéresse alors d'être sans
ballon aux y prenons le deuxième acte
sanitas débuts du duo pour les places
alors bien entendu
bien entendu on saute son homologue du
début quand tu fais chaque flacon
pendant les répétitions au théâtre
suggestions si on coupait complètement
le monologue un merci les un vrai homme
de théâtre
merci de poire de proposer spontanément
ce qui s'impose et dont je n'ai pas osé
de parler jusqu'ici de couper ce
cataplasme qu'il faut que tu me prends
pour qui
tu sais très bien qu'il aurait pas
accepté ce rôle qu'il n'y avait pas le
monologue le toupet n'en est pas
question une seconde 1
parce que toi metteur en scène de génie
dans l'âme net tu ferai voter
tranquillement le monologue
je te remercie en tout cas pour la
comparaison en tout cas à l'idée qu'on
puisse le coupé n'a pas eu l'air de
troubler non masque florent savez très
bien que julien ne se laisserait pas
amputer bondi de 5,6 ce n'est pas pour
défendre ton texte j'ai engagé pourquoi
alors un un acteur de mon niveau
dans la situation actuelle voulez vous
le dire pour jouer les vedettes
il faut vous dire mon saint maxin que
bien peu d'acteurs sont capables de
résister aux monologues parce que le
monologue c'est la consécration
mais vous hissez c'est le bâton de
maréchal mais bien moins cher directrice
j'ai besoin de répéter je vais même
retravaillé toute la matinée dans le
calme et la concentration va le revoir
dans le jardin mais épargnez nous ton
morceau de bravoure guillaume
ne vous énervez pas calmez vous tenez je
savais dans ma bibliothèque vous y serez
très bien merci beaucoup moins cher m
ben vous en faites une tête oui mais le
seul fait d'entendre se relancer les
langes de ce virus mais souffrant
toujours malade je le sais vous a
égratigné égratigné mais on voulait
rater oui couvert d'insultés couvert
couverts de boue d'être le seul il avait
avec une telle mauvaise foi nous telle
méchanceté dans les propos que ces
articles ont relevé plus de la
diffamation de la critique
tous les auteurs maltraités aussi moussa
je vous assure que j'ai eu droit
vraiment à un tarif préférentiel sa
manière poursuit avec une ténacité qui
ressemble à de la haine c'est parce
qu'il vous envie florent son hostilité
traduit sa rage de l'avoir jamais pu
réussir à écrire une pièce
donc nous allons voir quelque chose
j'ai demandé elle y est d'apporter du
champagne afin de baptiser votre
nouvelle
ils ne font pas que l'arrivée de ce
monsieur jette un trouble dans notre
petite réunion on s'amusait bien charlie
en passant n'oubliez pas de servir une
coupe empoisonné à bureaux
as-tu c'est florent nous sommes tous
logés à la même enseigne et pas toi là
j'avais cité qui me l'a assez répété à
le pire des afro il m'ignore comme si je
n'existais pas il a fait une bonne
pratique de la pièce de peretti
il a cité toute la distribution
jusqu'aux plus petits rôles sur la mise
en scène sur mon travail rien sommes là
tu aurais préféré d azur dans les études
enfin une mise en scène qui ne se
remarque pas mais c'est ce qu'on peut
réussir de mieux non heureusement il
n'est pas unique buron ses confrères eux
le m'ignore pas de bonnes critiques j'en
ai partout jusqu'au chili matin quand
j'ai présenté d'avoir la double
inconstance
j'ai été couverts de fleurs par l'étoile
du soir et par le soleil levant de pékin
ça se finit le chinois on m'a traduit au
alors vous pensez bien si je me fous que
buron ne même pas senti en ce compris
alors en revanche toit soit jamais eu la
teneur des tombereaux de fleurs tout
paris a rigolé
parce que tout paris rigole quand on
trouve vite à l'heure du talent tu en as
bon d'accord c'est entendu monf a du
génie
simplement monsieur bureau on trouve
notre petite caroline à son goût j'en
suis ravi pour toi mon nom je met l'art
dramatique n'a rien à voir là dedans
vous êtes des mufles je vous ferai
remarquer que tous les autres papiers
étaient tout aussi élogieux
alors vous allez certainement conclure
que tous ces messieurs ont envie de voir
ma chérie je les comprends bref alors
toi justement tu peux pas comprendre
j'ai là ton charme et compréhensible
pour tous oui toi tu l'as compris tout
de suite je suis sûr que caroline
préfére être apprécié pour ses qualités
de comédienne
ce que pour ses autres qualités est-ce
pas caroline qu'on puisse hésiter à la
situation ma chère on doit passer par là
ah oui ça c'est vrai je suis passé mais
tu vois moi je me suis pas installé
et bien moi c'est ici que je peux
m'installer
tu trouveras une autre puis celle pour
me remplacer aubry je t'en prie ne fais
pas ta mauvaise elle est surtout un
grand soin pour qu'elle n'est jamais une
bonne critique sinon ici ça risque de
déplaire je vais on ne rend pas à tel
rôle comme ça sur un coup de tête qu'il
faut le concéder money ne pensait pas un
mot de ce qu'elle disait sa manière bien
sûr une bonne fille née toubel faut pas
exagérer non un long couteau rejetons
ont pris mais j'ai embrassé vous
rabaisser la féliciter c'est la joie on
pourrait demander à bureaux de venir se
joindre à nous a aussi dit les
excellentes idées étant donné que je ne
vivrai pas un général le haut comment
vous ne verrez pas a sûrement prat il
déteste ce genre de pièce je n'ai pas du
tout envie de voir ce monsieur de mon
théâtre a été bien voilà ce que les ne
pouvons pas interdire au public de
liévin trouve âge ils sont prises bien
tout seul à ma connaissance pourtant
vous n'avez jamais eu personnellement à
vous plaindre la critique le haut j'en
ai eu ma terre ferme
oui mais dans le temps mais l'académie a
ceci de grosses séquelles vous met
quasiment à l'abri dello sport mon chien
bâti mais permettez vous êtes allé me
refaire une beauté puisque money quel
luxe inutile vous êtes toujours charmant
maxime mais laissez moi passer quand
même
l'écomusée blisters salle de flore à
propos de buron
il ya une anecdote qui me vient à
l'esprit
je ne résiste pas au plaisir de vous la
conter il y a quelques années il a vendu
visite à mes confrères goncourt et il
lui a dit à peu près ceci je n'ai aucune
chance d'avoir le pris mais je vous
demande de voter comme au premier tour
sa manière je n'aurais qu'une voix mais
ça me fera chaud que de penser que c'est
la vo ce n'est pas là qu'on rit alors on
va pas se laisser fléchir et le jour du
dépouillement tous les bons coups et
veut des bourgs bureau parce qu'il avait
fait la même démarche auprès de tous les
académiciens
ce sera pour une autre fois il a fallu
procéder au vote quel canal
quel culot mais dresser votre obligé
parce que sans lui vous florent sans lui
vous continueriez d'écrire mais sans
vous lui il n'irait plus c'est vous qui
lui donné l'importance en tout cas je ne
vois pas ce qu'il y aurait de scandaleux
à ce qu'il soit reçu un jour sous la
coupole
il mérite tout de même mieux d'y siéger
que le duc demi branche d'hybrides le
même fauteuil et dont personne n'a
jamais lu un seul livre on lui au moins
les cris bien il écrit vient buron
ajavon incompréhensive un charabia didon
à propos de charabia
alors là revenons à ta pièce il ya une
approche qui est impossible à dire
laquelle on demande mais c'est qu'ils y
faisaient ce qu'ils au téléphone à
excuser moi mon cher m c'est la peine
que j'attendais donc je vous avais parlé
et c'est l'exact non merci beaucoup plus
tranquille merci même évolué m'excuser
l'instant ça voilà c'est pas me raser
nommé écoute moi ça c'est l'âge est en
congé qui a jeté la caissette de se
casser c'est quoi ça c'est ce que tu as
écrit ça c'est l'agent en congés qui a
jeté la question des assiettes cassées
une impossible à dire ça c'était
maintenant ou jamais aucun acteur ne
pourra dire comme ça d'une façon
désinvolte à vous savez c'est l'âge a
rencontré qui a jeté la tête du verre de
même trois fois et très bien vous ne
sais pas moi qui le dit dans la pièce et
le dit si bien ce que tu peux te
désagréable on ne peut jamais parlé avec
toi je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mot sur maxime et prénom nom ne me
demandez pas prendre parti je voudrais
pour rien au monde m'immiscer dans vos
petites querelles
pas facile cette menace est pas moi qui
l'écrit vous inquiétez pas mon cher ami
on se querelle comme ça mais en réalité
on s'adore le théâtre c'est une grande
famille oh là là les atrides messieurs
monsieur c'est la police la police mais
oui à l'inspecteur qui demandent si
c'est ici que se tient la réunion à sa
cause devant la réunion
mais en tout cas il dit que c'est très
sérieux et bien fait de rentrer en
traîneau style personne ne bouge
il est important que chacun reste à sa
place et n'utiliser de sortir a concerné
des maisons l'ordre tiraient du tout mon
cher maître je vous présente andré
lambert un comédien de notre troupe qui
va jouer le rôle de l'inspecteur dans ma
pièce et dont les facéties ne seconde
que vous m'avez réellement impressionné
monsieur v j'ai le coeur fragile
je sais pas comment m'excuser mais elles
n'ont pas non plus de neuf heures et est
passé plutôt bien au menu genevois des
bourgeons ma chérie comment vas tu mais
la fois à la plus belle
[Musique]
au service à bao di dio vivian tan rouge
à lèvres a débordé mais avant cela la
jetro victoire au bout et julien il est
là c'est mieux que ce que tu veux lutter
devenir ce que j'ai besoin de tout le
monde mais aussi bâti dans la
distribution et qu'on cesse manon
justement il reste encore 1 euro la
distribuer et nous passons dans trois
semaines à venir il ya eu une réponse de
fedor il mène en bateau il ne le fera
pas je suis persuadé qu'elle devra bon
rythme alors là tu rêves ils me doivent
au coûteux devrait même encore davantage
que ça ne changerait pas grand chose ou
est ce que tu as entendu parler de
reconnaissance au théâtre de leurs
connaissances c'est une qualité de
chiens c'est pas une qualité cabo où
j'ai de toit sont guillaume je crois que
je viens à raison parce que depuis qu'il
a tourné trois films faits d'or à la
tête comme ça on se demande pourquoi je
les trouvais mauvais quand son dernier
free and on and on manie pas mauvais pas
bon verre très bas et depuis n'a reçu
aucune proposition rien ben oui pourtant
il paraît qu'il est chez lui toute la
journée ainsi pas son téléphone sur une
petite chaise
mettez-vous à sa place tous les copains
de sa génération sont fait un nom au
cinéma ça me rend malade
on voit si tu veux mon avis d'intention
fedor et téléphones dont tout de suite à
un bond il ya là comme ça on sera
tranquilles on dit là bas ce sera dans
la place c'est un vrai robinet d'eau qui
a bondi vers l'avant c'est solide ça
s'est tellement solide que ça vous
assomme on ne sont relève le rôle déjà
votre foi la madjer addip qui est acculé
à la faillite ne fait pas et guillaume
et avec isaac body gaza sera le mur des
lamentations bon je vous laisse
réfléchir tâcher de trouver un nom je
vous mets en mission d'aller demander un
verre d'eau à eliette parce que j'ai un
médicament à prendre je connaissais je
me lance
que diriez-vous de doucet ah ça c'est
l'idée du jour on ne pouvait pas plus
mal tomber
là vraiment le contraire du rôle
admettons que j'ai rien dit
puis tout c'est audrey trafi chaussée du
titre à sa wii ait mme banon
le run justifie par son talent en double
c'est gravé là avec la valeur ridicule
il est très bien
seulement chaque fois qu'on avance le
monde elle aussi vite qu'ils trouvent
quelque chose à ça je sais très bien que
tu les trouves toi adou c'est un nom
vous disputez pas on sait ma chérie que
tu as eu des faiblesses pour lui mais
c'est de l'histoire ancienne tout ça ah
bon d'accord parce que tous aient aussi
ont une saveur
alors là je te manque vraiment pardon
caroline julien tu vas pas être jaloux
rétrospectivement des tous les amendes
caroline mais on n'en sortira jamais
cass alors là vraiment me dit tu
exagères caroline écoute ça y est
maintenant série non leurs pattes à
brochure c'est qu'est ce que tu cherches
eh bien je te ferai pas ce plaisir je
reste je voulais pas du tout le faire de
peine à cette idiote
bien sûr que non non si je peux me
permettre de digressions il ya un acteur
que j'aime beaucoup moi c'est granier
c'est à dire je ne sais pas si le rôle
lui conviendrait j'avais pensé à lui en
tout premier lieu mais c'est impossible
et pourquoi il voudrait pas non c'était
pas ça mais si nous prenons granier nous
perdons lisbeth caron ils sont fâchés à
mort
et comme l'ami de mademoiselle caron
autres pour 30% dans mon affaire
les temps sont trop difficiles pour que
je puisse supporter seul les risques
d'une telle entreprise
vous pensez machine il me manque encore
10 % oui vous voulez dire un associé à
10%
mais alors exactement un associé à 10%
mais je ne vois pas un oui ça se voit
oui pourquoi c'est tellement difficile
de trouver des associés pour une foule à
la salle devient mon cher m vous
connaissez beaucoup de pigeons vous qui
veulent entrer dans une affaire en étant
seulement intéressé au déficit a presque
jamais de bénéfices mais si beaucoup
beaucoup
pour le directeur pour le producteur
jamais donc le sort de polytechnique
mais il ya là une
hermétique qui me dépasse je ne l'écouté
pas maxime il dit n'importe quoi pour
essayer de me faire passer pour une
fripouille
maintenant ce qu'il oublie de vous dire
c'est que enfin tous les associés
reçoivent chaque semaine des comptes
scrupuleux et qu'il vous sera très
facile de vérifier vous même un peu
libero o merci maxime alors la merci
beaucoup mais vraiment ce à quoi je vous
souhaite diriger à vous aurez bien du
plaisir tu alors vous faites à crocheter
vendre mais tu refuse toutes les offres
qui te sont faites pas bien sûr elles
sont dérisoires
si ça vaut tellement cher c'est que ça
rapporte beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'ambert damman boudaud mer demain qu'on
aura une autre habilleuse enfin je t'en
ai déjà parlé la pauvre lucienne ne peut
pas tout faire et surtout ne tient plus
debout tu sais c'est pas avec ce qu'elle
gagne qu'elle peut manger de la viande
tous les jours où tout verra on verra
pour lucienne et puis c'est tout
buras on verra on verra qu'on va faire
que les spectacles pas faire parce que
j'aurai raté mes entrées j'ai des
changements rapides
s'il fallait faire tout seul en
soutenant lucie elle par dessus le
marché alors là on court au désastre est
la raison et au sujet de l'accessoiriste
tu t'es décidé enfin de son régisseur
peut pas faire tout tout seul non plus
sinon le voyons il te fait à régis i te
fais tes courses ir palais lors des 10
dom et qu'est-ce que tu dois bien lui
faire pour qu'il te sois si dévoués bah
rien du tout alors je me demande bien
quand on bat pour en revenir à la
distribution pourquoi pas bernard violet
à je lui ai téléphoné il m'a répondu je
cite qu'il cherchait une pièce qui lui
permettent de se plonger dans une
créativité qui ait valeur de
communication à qu'il avait besoin de se
revitaliser au contact d'éléments
susceptibles de lui apporter un plus
grand panorama
alors j'ai vacanciers enfin c'est est
excité au contraire qui nous a rebattu
les oreilles et on sait s'en remettre
puis ton histoire vector studio andrée
voudrais tu ne savais pas mais guillaume
a terminé sa crise non il a réintégré la
grande famille du théâtre de boulevard
la famille du théâtre des demeurés
de toute façon nous jours dans un
théâtre
nous n'aurions pas eu bernard violet ou
voulait-il d'anjou est ce un jeune homme
clamé partout partout sauf dans un
théâtre
mais les préférences dans un regard ah
oui et un lieu où mieux maxime mieux un
espace vide le plus souvent à propos de
vide est avant que quelqu'un d'autre
n'établisse la comparaison si on
revenait à la lecture de ma pièce mais
je crois que votre travail précieux
monjalous bon ami à mon art un peu plus
tôt un peu plus tard cela vraiment
aucune importance si vous voulez
reprenons simplement la fin du match
j'ai quitté dirait bureau puisque sa
présence vous est désagréable ce ne soit
pas le voile à bord nous reprendre à
julien turcotte à sortir on va regarder
je vais chercher le professeur ne
laissez pas seuls
non je ne serai pas là c'est ça vous
oubliez que je suis là nous n'avons rien
à craindre tant que nous resterons tous
ensemble et surtout si si l'assassin est
dans la maison
pourquoi le professeur n'était pas des
mouches c'est un homme étrange
il me fait peur pourquoi il y avait vu
demander de venir mois j'ignorais son
existence jusqu'à ce soir
mais alors pourquoi
le professeur
le professeur est quoi le professeur il
est mort on l'a assassiné monsieur le
siège de kylie a dit l'ailier
monsieurbureau monsieurbureau reda
quoique je me rends au parmi les morts
ou l'assassiner
[Applaudissements]
personne n'a rien vu
moi moi j'ai senti quelque chose
une présence invisible impalpable et
j'ai entendu des bruits de pas sur le
tapis ses courses il me trouvait mal
vous y croyez maintenant à notre
histoire de croquemitaine oui je suis
médium et depuis un moment des
transmissions voltigent autour de moi
comme des ombres
il n'y a rien dans tout cela le
surnaturel où j'avais beaucoup bu et
cela excite votre imagination
c'est moi c'est moi qui ai inventé cette
histoire de village mondy 1
il a raison protégez nous il existe dans
cette pièce quelque chose de magnifique
je vais chercher le professeur et le
laissez passer devant une seconde mais
je crois que c'est là qu'on s'est fait
arrêter si on est certes un certain
louis jullien raison à oui c'est exact
nous nous étions arrêtés car eliette
était venu annoncer un mètre sans éclair
la limite du rhône offrent un ballon
quand il y était entré nous étions déjà
interrompu arch ses terres en gaz
il veut savoir où j'arrive tout ça s'est
brouillée dans ma mémoire à vous avez ce
drame chez moi et puis la réalité a
suivi de situer l'action de votre pièce
longue j'en ai été bouleversé
genève may plus même impressionné je
suis incapable
excusez moi monsieur mais ne me demandez
pas plus c'est moi qui vous prie de
m'excuser mon chermette de vous avoir
demandé de prendre part à cette
reconstitution je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté c'est tout naturel voyez vous
c'est la première fois que je me trouve
en face d'un académicien au milieu d'une
troupe de comédiens se veut dire que je
suis moi même un peu déconcerté vous ne
donnez pas du tout l'impression
commissaire il faut pas se fier aux
apparences main vous disiez monsieur
vous ne vous êtes pas arrêtée à cause de
l'arrivée de monsieur buron pourquoi
alors avez-vous interrompu votre lecture
c'est moi qui voulais donner quelques
indications aux comédiens pour une
meilleure compréhension de la pièce à il
comprenait pas ce que je veux dire je
vais parler de la psychologie des
personnages de la façon de les aborder
de les concevoir
je voulais leur faire part à ce sujet de
quelques réflexions personnelles par
exemple je me souviens pas exactement
c'est sans grande importance on ne
croyait pas ça
comprenez bien que tous vous entendez
bien tout peut m'être utile le plus
petit détail peut être un indice au
moment du meurtre vous étiez bien tous
placés comme tout à l'heure et on line
tu n'étais pas au jardin comment
mademoiselle vous étiez dans le jardin
pendant cette compétition c'est du
jargon théâtrale au jarret cela veut
dire à droite
regardons le public et la course de
l'autre côté c'est comme tribord et
bâbord dans la marine et d'où viennent
ces traditions de louis callens
commissaire quand on jouait à hot wheels
ri devant le roi est bien à gauche se
trouvait la cour d'honneur et à droite
les jardins oui et pendant la répétition
nous avions imaginé le public l'a voit
l'avenir la raison pour laquelle voyez
les meubles disposer ainsi c'est le
canton répète on imagine toujours qu'il
ya du public en face quand on joue il y
en a plus mais alors bon les doigts et à
quel moment la gouvernante tel annoncé
l'arrivée de la victime mais fleurant
viens de vous le dire commissaire nous
venions juste de nous interrompt moselle
il y est
mademoiselle eliette voulez vous avoir
la gentillesse de refaire les mêmes
gestes de prononcer les mêmes paroles
qu'avant-hier aux riches d'essayer
je vous remercie allons-y dis moi vous
allez vous eh bien je sois prêt parle
alors je sors ah oui pardon
monsieur c'est la police les embrouilles
et vous venez annoncé à votre maître
l'arrivée de monsieur buron aux excuses
et match ici tellement aimé je sais
juste que chez moi
non ne ressortait pas inutile à écouter
monsieur sy soir offert comme avant-hier
way seront faits comme avant-hier
alors je sors
monsieur monsieur viron viens d'arriver
je lui ai dit que vous n'attendez pas si
tôt mais il m'a dit comprendre il s'est
installé dans le petit salon
voilà j'ai l'impression d'entendre la
lecture d'un télégramme enfin
l'essentiel y est ils étaient bien trois
heures et monsieur bur on avait rendez
vous à 5h tête exact il a prétendu que
vous aviez avancer l'heure de votre
rendez vous
c'est ce qu'elle y est t'as compris
j'imagine m que vous devez avoir
beaucoup de choses en tête
à ceci que vous auriez très bien pu
oublier un coup de téléphone à monsieur
buron l'entrevue avec lui n'étant pas
d'une importance capitale pour vous
j'imagine je n'ai rien oublié du tout
monsieur et même si j'avais eu une
petite absence peut être insistant sur
vite remis les choses en place
envoyez-vous j'essaie de ne rien
négliger pour ne pas orienter au départ
mon enquête dans une mauvaise direction
mais j'avais compris je vous remercie
bien
eliette est sorti que s'est-il passé
ensuite
bien que nous avons bavardé comme
d'habitude de quoi abattre ans
comme d'habitude rompus sur le dos de
buron comme d'habitude oui le pauvre il
n'a vraiment pas eu de chance
ne vous gênez pas pour moi je sais très
bien qu aucun d'entre vous n'avez une
raison particulière de le porter dans
son coeur de la tuer bizier monsieur bur
on était venu vous voir dans l'espoir
d'entrer à l'académie française
oui c'est nous appelons cela monsieur
une visite protocolaire avait t-il une
chance je ne crois pas il devait pouvoir
en tout cas penser compter sur votre
voix j'imagine jeudi magie dans des
faits avait-il tort questions
indiscrètes véraison excusez moi je me
suis laissé entraîner
m'enfin pouvez vous me dire quelle a été
la réaction des personnes présentes ici
pour ce qui me concerne j'avoue que j'ai
été assez surpris je ne m'attendais pas
à cette candidature va pourtant après
cela démissionner je ne lis pas les
jambes je me suis livrée d'ailleurs à
aucun commentaire j'ai simplement fait
part à notre hôte de mon étonnement je
n'aimais pas buron c'est de notoriété
publique
mais je ne lui ai jamais nié un certain
talent je regrettais simplement qu'il
ait mis son talent au service de ce que
je considère comme une mauvaise cause
parler de la critique en général ou
celle de vous qui vous concerne et plus
particulièrement je parle en général
j'ai fait rechercher tous les articles
que buron vous a consacré à tous ces
dernières années je vous trouve
particulièrement indulgent ce sont
autant d'appels au meurtre
j'ai là un dossier qu'on pourrait
baptiser circonstances atténuantes à la
limite vous et vous pourrez dire que
vous étiez presque tous en état de
légitime défense
il est vrai que parfois sa plume était
plus dangereuse la revolver mais c'est
la règle du jeu
il faut l'accepter comment ça j'ai
l'impression d'un jeu où les dés sont
pipés où les atouts sont toujours dans
la même main pas souvent l'occasion
d'aller au théâtre mais enfin j'ai eu
l'année dernière des billets à prix
réduit pour aller voir votre pièce
l'étoile filante un titre prédestiné
écoutez moi j'avais passé une très bonne
soirée ont néanmoins si je peux me
permettre une petite réserve je vais pas
beaucoup aimé la fin enfin je viens de
lire la critique de monsieur durand je
la trouve très exagérées merci alors je
suis très sincère écoutez franchement
quand je lis vous avait mitonné un avec
re dans un ragoût débile en
l'assaisonnant de dialogue de garçons de
bain c'est pas prêt gens qui font ça ni
pour les garçons de bain un idiot je
vous remercie en tout cas de m'en avoir
rappelé les termes exacts donc c'est
très exagéré mois sera vous me serais
restée sur l'estomac
pas vous j'ai eu des crampes en effet
mais j'estime que le mépris est un
remède plus salutaire que la vengeance
vous avez raison clan monsieur en
littérature les injures les plus graves
sont la plupart du temps réglé par
l'oubli mais je me rends pas bien compte
en tout cas monsieur bur ont bavé pas
paru particulièrement sensible au talent
de mademoiselle ce n'est que justice
caroline a beaucoup de talent elle le
mérite bien
c'est ce que nous disions tous
avant-hier si je peux me permettre moi
aussi de donner mon avis je vous ai vu
mademoiselle de la semaine dernière à la
télévision dont je ne sais plus quelle
bêtise vous étiez très bien
merci monsieur le commissaire vous avez
dû faire des progrès rapides
je sais pas peut-être pourquoi j'ai tout
vrai parce que j'ai là deux critiques de
monsieur buron d'été de l'année dernière
t'es pas particulièrement tendres
tendres ils n'avaient pas su déceler
apparemment le jeune talent qui était en
venant fesser bien de le reconnaître
maintenant vous le connaissiez comme ça
je l'avais rencontrée par ci par là dans
des endroits publics à des général nous
avions échangé quelques mots quelques
mots donc conversation d'ordre général
sur la critique est sûre buron en
particulier lequel est là dans la pièce
à côté
rêvant peut-être qu'il va devenir
immortel est le moment ou jamais
alors que son assassin est ici dans
cette pièce commissaire vous voulez dire
parmi nous c'est exact vous plaisantez
monsieur pas du tout m l'un de nous un
assassin côté voilà une idée amusante je
ne trouve pas chère madame voyez vous je
viens d'étudier la topographie des
guildes par invraisemblable que
l'assassin soigneux l'extérieur vous qui
pâtissent et des histoires policières il
y avait certainement déjà pensé savez il
ya très loin de la réalité à la fiction
et pour la première fois que je suis
plongée en direct dans la vérité j'avoue
que je ne me suis pas posé de question à
vous me surprenez vous concocté dans
votre cabinet des intrigues policières
compliqué vous semblait indifférent ou
trouver en face d'eux problèmes concrets
votre opinion mon cher collègue pas très
gentil
dans quelques mois je ne me moque pas la
fonction crée l'organe pourquoi le rôle
ne craint-il pas la vocation vous
interprétez des commissaires des
policiers des détectives des inspecteurs
et le physique mais sur le commissaire
nhtsa j'ai jamais pu en sortir
j'ai débuté dans la recelle l'upa et le
rôle du sergent de ville
quand on pense à moi c'est toujours pour
un flic à j'ai bien essayé au début de
ma carrière de mentir et j'ai même
refusé deux rôles dans des films
policiers
quand je me suis rendu compte qu'on
m'appellerait jamais pour proposer
tromper un autre personnage eve
j'ai réintégré la police qu'est ce que
voulait fallait bien que je me fasse je
serai flic tout mal d'autant que
physiquement vous êtes beaucoup plus
crédible que moi vous ne vous en preniez
pas certains aiment beaucoup la grande
maison à ça c'est vrai alors plus j'ai
pas payer une seule contravention du lac
d'ailleurs dans la rue les flics les les
agents me reconnaissent et du salut vous
bénéficiez de tous les avantages de
notre profession sans en connaître les
inconvénients vous gravissez les
échelons de la hiérarchie vous finirez
préfet de police oui à l'ancienneté
puisse vous poser une question
commissaire vous en prie madame vous
avez dit tout à l'heure qu'il était peu
probable que l'assassin soit venu de
l'extérieur
pourquoi trois raisons la première c'est
qu'il est très difficile d'entrer dans
la propriété sans se faire remarquer le
portail est muni d'un oeil électronique
et eliette surveille toutes les entrées
et les sorties
c'est exact on peut sauter le mur avec
une petite échelle sont pas dire
impossible
j'ai dit très difficile d'entrer sans se
faire remarquer encore plus d'en sortir
deuxièmement pourquoi l'assassin
sera-t-il vu commettre son forfait ici
pour faire de chacun de nous un suspect
ou c'était prendre de bien gros risques
troisièmement il aurait fallu qu'il soit
au courant de la visite de monsieur bur
ont en tout cas personne d'entre nous
ici n'était au courant de cette visite
c'est vous qui le dites
non je peux vous affirmer monsieur vous
aviez un baiser affirmé qu' ils ont tous
manifesté la plus grosse surprise en
apprenant cette visite et moi le premier
parce que je l'attendais que deux heures
plus tard écoutez mon cher maître ne
fait pas injure à vos amis ce sont tous
d'excellents comédiens pour qui simule
et la surprise est un jeu d'enfant on
n'y avait pas pensé
écoutez comme ici à je dois dire au nom
de tous mes camarades que je trouve vos
insinuations fort déplaisante ne vous
fâchez pas mal je croyais que dans votre
métier ont pratiqué un certain sens de
l'humour
depuis j'essaie de ne pas dramatiser la
situation promet les journalistes ne
partage pas votre sentiment monsieur une
nouvelle a d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
aime ce qu'on a le critique assassine et
c2c
habitué de l'académie française en mai
vous pouvez pas y échapper c'est de
l'information issa subissent et ça c'est
la formation
bon du rififi quai conti du rouge sur un
habit vert
une question que de moi le contenu vos
l'emballage
il s'attaque à ma vie privée et bien
c'est bart monsieur c'est immonde
c'est répugnant non soyez tranquilles il
n'épargne personne
vous ne pouvez jamais arrêter les
divagations de journalistes avides de
sensations et non les comédiens en mal
de publicité d'aller se montrer à la
télévision
c'est pour moi plus dix ans absolument
j'ai tout un sens et de profiter de la
situation pour aller parader à la télé
si encore tu avais parlé de la pièce
bien alors j'en ai parlé ça a été coupée
ce n'est pas ma faute
bon et puis alors si je suis allé à la
télé c'est parce qu'on m'a demandé moi
j'étais sollicité moi aussi figure toi
mais j'ai refusé
c'est pas moi question de décence oh
merci madame la directrice
voilà une leçon de modestie à laquelle
qui nous a pas habitués en gt prix je
viens tout cas moi je vous félicite
chère madame je n'ai justement vous
demandez à tous la plus grande
discrétion pendant le déroulement de
l'enquète est de nouveau prêté à aucune
interview coûté commissaires pourraient
ce que vous voulez après tu peux même
vous promettre que l'un d'entre vous
race à photographier en première page de
tous les journaux
bon revenons à nos moutons pu quand
monsieur bur on avait une sollicité sans
des mois c'est à moi que oui c'était le
jour de la séance du dictionnaire
monsieur laquelle mon état de santé ne
permettait pas d'assister le fait que
bureau m'appelle ce jour là chez moi sa
mère et ça m'avait frappé c'était donc
jeudi et à cinq jours jusqu'à preuve du
contraire
puis je me permettre ça comme ça mais je
vous en prie mon cher collègue
merci si dur on a été assassiné avec le
revolver de mettre sinclair il fallait
donc le meurtrier sache où étaient
rangées la has et une déduction qui
s'imposent et le peut dans sa chair que
d'un familier mais j'ai jamais dit que
ce revolver est l arme du crime j'ai dit
qu'il s'agissait d'un 6 35 et que
c'était avec une arme de ce type que la
victime avait été retenu ah oui alors
même si si si on peut tout de même se
demander précisément à quoi il manque
une balle dans le chargeur de cette arme
seul m sinclair pourrait me dire
malheureusement il se souvient plus je
peux plus je vais c'est en main depuis
très longtemps dans un tiroir de
secrétaire
je me l'étais jamais servi la maison est
très isolé alors vous dire si le
chargeur était complet et aussi bien à
quatre et vous ne vous souvenez pas non
plus si cette arme était à sa place au
début la répétition
l'idée de le vérifier le mot n'est pas
venu je ne pouvais pas avoir besoin
supposée en tout cas avoir besoin d'une
arme l'occasion de cette réunion amicale
mais c'est là sous les papiers sa seule
présence suffisait de me donner un
sentiment de sécurité
et personne non plus n'a entendu la
moindre détonations l'assassin dû servir
d'un silencieux
il fallait l'adapter à l'armée par
conséquent en connaître la nature
enfin passons c'est pas grave nous
serons très foot c est comment également
expliqué que cette armée puisse se
retrouver dans le tiroir simple détail
des deux mises en scène à la sas a très
bien pu la placer dans le tiroir du
bureau en profitant de l'affolement et
du désordre qui ont dû s'installer après
l annonce de la découverte du marque qui
s'est approché de ce bureau noir moi je
me suis approché du bureau je voulais
prendre mon sac que j'avais envie de
fumer une cigarette dans un pareil
moment
oui c'est toujours dans ces moments-là
que j'éprouve le besoin de fumer mais
vos camarades ils s'étaient tous
précipités dans le petit salon vous
étiez donc seul devant ce boulot non
monsieur sinclair il était déjà et qui
faisait vous je cherchais le numéro de
téléphone de la gendarmerie de
rambouillet que j'avais noté sur mon
agenda
avant même de savoir si elle y est
s'était trompé à écouter commissaire je
ne souhaitais pas très savante mais
quand je vois un homme les yeux grands
ouverts avec du sang plein la tête
je me doute quand même qui s'est passé
quelque chose de pas très normal non
en effet mais reprenons l'ordre
chronologique qui d'entre vous est
sortie pendant la répétition mois moi je
suis allé dans la bibliothèque la
conversation de vos camarades vous
ennuyer on pas du tout comme il sert
mais j'avais besoin de revoir mon texte
avant la suite de la répétition
j'ai un long tunnel aux 2,1 quoi un
tunnel un monologue en termes
professionnels
or en tout cas je rends hommage à votre
belle conscience professionnelle non
merci comme ils serrent vous savez le
talent ne suffit pas faute aussi
beaucoup de travail moule mais julien
n'a pas quitté la bibliothèque
commissaire comme on le savait où nous
l'avons tous entendue n'est ce pas il
n'a pas cessé de dire son rôle va c'est
la dernière édition du journal du soir
monsieur à il ya du nouveau
continuez à vue avant dé encore les
lieux du crime
mais comment tu fais pour prendre les
photos de ce salon était mené 5 à 10 ans
mais non monsieur ça m'étonnerait que ce
soit les mêmes vous ce dernier est mort
ça monsieur il ya trois ans vous n'aviez
pas encore le masque vaudou kellock ce
délit va souvenez vous vous la fait
ramener en février en même temps quoi de
la barre oui c'est vrai à la raison
et puis si vous voulez mon avis hein eh
bien ces deux photos elles ont été
prises hier matin par ici j'étais
justement en train de faire le ménage et
pas regarder là on voit bout du tuyau de
l'aspirateur et bien tenez c'est à peu
près comment l'inspecteur est venu que
l'inspecteur a expliqué nous sommes à 12
heures et est bien hier matin un homme
est venu il m'a dit qu'il était
inspecteur de police et qu'il venait
votre part j'ai envoyé personne enfin
s'il n'a montre une carte mais il m'a
dit qu'il venait pour pour les photos
d'identité judiciaire et même que
c'était pas la peine de déranger
monsieur qui est encore dans sa chambre
si je comprends bien on m'a trompé non
mais moi je trouvais pas ça parce que
c'est pas votre route vous n'avez rien à
vous reprocher mais c'est
invraisemblable âgées scandaleux
j'appelle le préfet n'en fait rien mais
vous ne pourrez pas empêché un
photographe ou un journaliste de
déguiser en bonne soeur en plombier ou
en policier pour parvenir à ses fins
courrier que pour pas être importuné
vous aviez couper votre ligne oui mais
j'en ai une seconde vie n'était pas que
personne ne connaît d'ailleurs où
presque personne
l'académie ma famille et quelques amis
si messi radon monsieur jean escaffre à
mon éditeur justement merci allô allô
maman oui bon bain un peu près oui oui
vous avez lu la presse c'est scandaleux
non vous appelez ça une bonne nouvelle
mais je ne partage pas du tout votre
sentiment à monsieur mais non les pros
question jamais je ne me prêterai cette
mascarade
non non non non non non j'ai pas eu le
droit jusqu'à un temps d'une publicité
malsaine pour faire dire au revoir et
iec tiendra non
on ne savait pas que ma prends mon
éditeur et bien que les libraires se
jette sur mon dernier dit c'est un oui
oui non il connaissait un départ assez
difficile d'ailleurs oui alors il m'a
proposé un nouveau tirage un nouveau
tirage et le bande annonce d'un loup
tout à fait douteuse
je me demande vraiment si je ne vis pas
un cauchemar en remettez vous mon cher m
non monsieur est ce que vous avez vous
en avez pour longtemps de ce que moi je
voudrais aller me reposer quelques
minutes encore si vous le permettez j'ai
besoin de savoir qui d'entre vous est
sorti et votre témoignage à tous mais
très précieux monsieur le commissaire
moi je me souviens c'est j'ai conduit ma
dame à la salle de bain oui en effet en
effet c'est exact oui j'avais demandé à
monsieur sinclair la permission d'aller
refaire une beauté
quand j'avais même ajouté c'était un
luxe inutile à vous êtes toujours
charmant maxime ça vous a pris longtemps
que vous êtes galant commissaire
ce n'est pas une réflexion que je vous
fais c'est une question que je vous pose
mais je suis incapable de vous répondre
je ne sais pas moi cinq minutes enfin à
10 peut-être mais vous n'avez rien vu
rien entendu
non je n'ai rien vu rien entendu je suis
désolé commissaire lorsque vous êtes
revenu dans ce salon avez vous remarqué
s'il manquait quelqu'un à 6,6 et
guillaume est en prêt lorsque je suis
sorti on te demander au téléphone enfin
je crois
ah oui oui en effet je me souviens
j'avais conduit monsieur téléphone louis
qui vous téléphonez ses personnels
d'être resté longtemps absent je pense
que oui mon correspondant est très
bavard l'identité de votre correspondant
est ce indispensable à mon avis oui oui
bien sûr vous pouvez refuser de répondre
enfin tôt ou tard je le saurai j'imagine
c'est l adjoint au maire du vésinet il y
avait une réunion du conseil municipal
au sujet de la future maison de la
culture
je suis bien placée pour être nommé
directeur et j'avais demandé qu'on me
téléphona le résultat alors aucune
décision n'a été prise avait donc encore
toutes vos chances je pense que oui
surtout maintenant que bureau est mort
voulez vous dire ceci
l'année dernière à la même époque
la presse avait annoncé un peu
prématurément semble-t-il votre
nomination à pontoise un poste similaire
j'ai là un petit article signé de
monsieur buron il ya quelques lignes
vous concernant je cite pour la santé
morale et l' équilibre cérébrale des
habitants du val d'oise
la nomination au poste de directeur de
la future maison de la culture du plus
inexistant des metteurs en scène
ils parlent de vous merci c et espérons
qu'il s'agit d'une fausse nouvelle est
que les édiles concernés choisiront
homme de théâtre qui soit capable
lorsqu'il ouvre un manuscrit de
comprendre ce qu'il lit fin de citation
je le connais c'est pas très gentil pour
vous' impôts même si c'est vrai alors la
commissaire vous allez un peu fort quand
je crois que vous m'avez mal compris je
voulais dire que même si le pensait il
ya une façon de dire les choses moins
brutale - blessant oui mais buron était
un homme odieux et cruel à la suite de
quoi tout naturellement les conseillers
municipaux vous en laisse est sans
nouvelles à la suite de quoi tout
naturellement j'ai cru site epuron pour
qu'il ne renouvelle pas au vésinet son
exploit de comptoir c'est vous qui le
dis c'est pas moi non mais vous pensez
je pense à tout monsieur donc rester un
certain temps que les phones je suis
revenu en même temps que caroline ja
lire fermez la porte quand on est entré
alors bon on voit aussi mademoiselle
vous étiez sortie où étiez vous allez
devinez comme serre
j'attendais pour cela le retour de ma
directrice mais si vous aviez vu ou
entendu quelque chose je vous le dirai
d'ailleurs je me suis absenté très peu
de temps vous me disiez monsieur vous
êtes revenu en même temps que
mademoiselle par la même porte
c'est exact laquelle est celle ci il ya
une imposte sur une petite table dans le
couloir c'est là je vais téléphoner
mademoiselle quand vous êtes rendus à la
salle de bains par où êtes-vous sorti
par ici commissaire alors pourquoi êtes
vous revenu par là pas le plus court
chemin
oui je m'étais perdu j'ai enfin j'avais
perdu mon chemin ac c'est donc ça donc
chacun d'entre vous est sorti un moment
quelconque sauf vous ce monsieur
non je suis sorti également je suis allé
à la cuisine demandé un verre d'eau à
elle y est je me suis rendu directement
la paille
vous connaissez bien la maison haut
depuis de nombreuses années j'ai
l'honneur d'être l'ami de monsieur
sinclair et à part vous personne d'autre
n'était venu dans cette maison avant
cette première répétition ou personne
enfin sauf money mais elle entendu bien
puisqu'il faut en parler
lorsque nous étions mariés florent et
moi eh oui monsieur saint clair nous
faisait l'amitié de nous inviter très
souvent ici et de très doux souvenir
reste attaché à cette maison
j'ai beaucoup regretté de ne plus voir
maxime ouimet
écoutez money noter qu'avant de venir me
rendre visite rien ne pouvait me faire
plus plus léger c'est bien mais j'avais
préféré tirer un trait définitif sur
tout ce qui me rappelait florent très
bien léger puisque l'année suivant vous
montiez une pièce de lui oui mais ça
c'est ça c'est le théâtre ça c'est le
travail commissaire il a aussi ses
exigences en revenons à votre sortie
vous est donc allé boire un verre d'eau
15 centilitres vous avez dû rencontrer
eliette dans la cuisine non je n'ai vu
personne
c'est très possible je ne passe tout de
même pas tout mon temps à l'office
connaissait beaucoup alliés pas souvent
toujours derrière la porte
je suis revenu au chinois d'après et
nous avons repris la lecture de la pièce
que nous avons interrompu quelques
instants plus tôt pour décider ensemble
du choix d'un acteur pour le rôle qu'ils
restaient à distribuer rôle que mon ami
sinclair avait eu la gentillesse de
tenir en attendant me redonne au mieux
mieux parce que ça m'amuse et c'était
une expérience nouvelle pour moi
vous cherchez quelque chose comme ça
ça mais qu'est ce que c'est petit
émetteur miniaturisés qui permet
d'écouter à distance toute notre
conversation quelqu'un écoute tout ce
que l'on dit ça je me doutais bien qu'il
ne se contenterait pas de l'image qu'il
leur faudrait aussi le son voyez que
c'est le faux policier qui a placé ce
bidule
oui enfin le vrai journaliste william à
micros chez moi j'appelle mon avocat en
fait tu aurais un maître vous donneriez
à toute cette affaire une publicité
supplémentaire ce qui n'est pas
souhaitée à 6,6 en retrait
il y aura deux publicités plus à servir
à la pièce a mené vous n'allez pas me
dire que vous avez toujours l'intention
de monter la pièce de plomb pourquoi pas
oui nous allons avoir des
avant-premières comme au quinté
apprenons n'aura jamais mes côtés j'ai
calculé au prix de la ligne dans les
journaux que nous avons ce matin plus de
200 millions de publicités et ça ne fait
que commencer
c'est formidable à un crime comme ça
faisait ça n'arrive pas florent des bois
contact quoi votre attitude est amoral
je m'en fous mon cher merci semencière
maximois j'ai signé les contrats
alors croyez vous que la moralité de mes
comédiens ira jusqu à me faire cadeau
d'aidé dit que je leur dois
si je ne nomme pas ma signature et bien
vous n'avez qu'à leur demander en tant
que délégué syndical moi je dis
consultons la base seulement la base
c'est moi
as tu te rends à mon avis tu vois
évidemment il serait stupide de ne pas
profiter de ces circonstances
exceptionnelles de lancement enfin j'ai
un théâtre sur les marches du personnel
à l'année et puis surtout j'ai pas
d'autres spectacles et puis pièce
aujourd'hui à marie ya plus l'auteur la
preuve c'est tout ce que j'ai trouvé je
peux pourtant pas à prouver qu'on se
serve d'un crime pour lancer un produit
de la maddalena de bureau pour
promouvoir une pièce sera bien la
première fois qu'il me draguent grâce à
dieu la dernière devait il vous faudra
remplacer le ou la coupable ne l'oublié
pas vous allez avoir un autre cadavre
sur les bras un commissaire le mien si
vous m'enlevez ma vedette la veille de
la générale money monique doucement
doucement on parle de vedettes et ils
croient tout de suite qu'il s'agit de
lui
en tout cas ce sera plus facile de
trouver un autre metteur en scène pour
faire ton travail et jouer ton petit
rôle qu'un autre acteur pour me
remplacer
ah oui en somme si je comprends bien le
seul qui ne soit plus indispensable à la
représentation c'est vous cher monsieur
puisse pas faire imaginer tout même pas
que que je vais me dénoncer pour sauver
le spectacle je connais beaucoup
d'auteurs qui serait capable de bien
pires pour ce faire jouer dites moi je
sers mettre l'ambiance avant-hier entre
les protagonistes étaient sorel et
détendue pour ou très agréable monsieur
oui nous avons sabler le champagne
le champagne mais vous m'aviez cassé sa
bôme et c'est un crime a pas un barbare
m
je vous présente mes excuses du haut on
trouve li autre oubli très grave
je suis sorti moi aussi pour demander un
ailier de servir le champagne
eliette elle n'est jamais là et liège
huy apportez-nous des rafraîchissements
10 en pagne banos ce n'est pas le jour
posent sans prague pendant laquelle vous
sortez tous à tour de rôle les pieds des
gens là monsieur qui samoa a besoin
comme ça je suis arrivée juste au moment
des vibrations l'eau je m'étais même
amusé à me faire passer pour un vrai
inspecteurs une blog que je fais toi
entendre c'est pas la peine est en vente
et messieurs sinclair a failli
s'évanouir n'aviez pas la conscience
tranquille supporte mal les émotions
monsieur c'est le privilège de l'âge en
somme si je comprends bien vous êtes le
seul policier est arrivé sur les lieux
du crime avant qu'il ne soit commis oui
peut-être l'était-il déjà oui ou
peut-être êtes-vous l'assassin oui
les points que s'est-il passé ensuite
vous avez repris la lecture après la
pause champagne oui rester quelques
répliques à dire voulez-vous avoir
l'amabilité de me le dire nous nous
sommes arrêtés je crois à l'instant où
le personnage que vous interprétez va
chercher le professeur c'est bien ça
c'est ça il vous voulez me dire les
dernières équipes de la carte de visite
à libérer vos lames ça comme celle là
mais va ils sont très bien il existe
dans cette pièce quelque chose de
maléfique
je vais chercher le professeur ne nous
laissez pas seuls
est ce que tu crois que c'est bien que
je sois de dos au public comme on répète
pour le commissaire allait ou non
seulement est ce que je peux enchaîner
lien suivant
je ne serai pas long qu'est-ce qu'il dit
aujourd'hui je suis là où je te demande
s'arrêter qu'est-ce qu'il dit ça répit
que j'atteins dire aujourd'hui que je
suis là vous oubliez que je suis là nous
n'avons rien à craindre tant que nous
resterons tous ensemble surtout si
l'assassin est dans la maison pourquoi
les professeurs n'est-il pas avec nous
le professeur non c'est un homme étrange
moi il me fait peur pourquoi il y avez
vous demandé de venir le professeur est
pas là
moi j'ignorais son existence jusqu'à ce
soir
mais alors pourquoi alors c'est bien
celle-là génie pourquoi ça y est on a
écouté la 3 pourquoi je suis jamais sur
lequel fonds sur l'amiante culture
qu'est ce que tu dis mais alors pourquoi
tout ça c est la bonne réponse pour le
moment rien n'est plus bête que ça
c'est la seconde année le progrès le
professeur quoi les professeurs je
profite
il est mort pour l'assassinât
merci rideau fin du premier acte une
pièce bouleversante mirza
et que s'est-il passé entre ce moment
est celui où elle y est t'es venu
annoncer sa macabre découverte
rien il est mort il est mort vous voulez
dire que les deux meurtres le vrai le
faux ont été annoncés presque
simultanément et c'est ça qui nous a
tellement troublés commissaire en effet
c'est pour le moins troublant ce que je
pourrais lire votre pièce monsieur
bienvenue je serai d'ailleurs heureux de
connaître l'avis d'un spécialiste
voilà vous nous faites beaucoup
d'honneur non mais si la réalité suit de
cyprès la fiction le nom du meurtrier de
monsieur bur on doit se trouver entre
les lignes
et puis j'ai hâte de savoir ce que vous
avez fait du rôle de l'inspecteur que
désirez-vous voir monsieur au jus de
fruits il n'y a pas autre chose il faut
que je vous remercie monsieur je vous
remercie parce que vous faites garder ma
maison est en ce moment avec ce drame je
suis un sale et c'est bien naturel
mais dites-moi chermette je voudrais
vous demander encore une petite
précision
nous y sommes pouvez vous m'avez dit
n'avoir reçu aucune visite ces derniers
temps oui en effet vous en êtes bien
certains absolument monsieur ma mémoire
n'est plus ce qu'elle était et us
qu'elle était née n'est pas aussi
défaillante que vous l'imaginez
remarquer que chaque fois que vous me
posez une question vous n'avez pas l'air
convaincu par ma réponse
excusez moi mon cher maître mais c'est
très important pour moi mais monsieur ça
l'est peut-être un peu pour moi aussi
pas de coups de téléphone sortant de
l'ordinaire je ne vois pas à mais si
monsieur souvenez-vous ce journaliste
suédois qui voulait à tout prix vous
parlez bah oui ben quoi j'avais oublié
c'est un fait normal qu'un journaliste
venu l'interviewer oui ces choses-là
d'habitude ont lieu lors d'un rendez
vous c'est ce que je vais proposer mais
partait à l'heure même pour la suède
il a téléphoné dans l'après midi avoir
des renseignements complémentaires
quelques jours est s ous il ya quelques
jours c'était jeudi jusqu'à preuve du
contraire
ceci pour quel journal travail et il
mais je suis empressé d'oublier
écoutez moi je souffrais d'une chose
c'est qu'il a dit qu'il voulait à tout
prix parler à monsieur avant de rentrer
dans son pays c'est tout vous pouvez la
croire sur quand elle n'est pas derrière
rapporte à l'état l'écouteur et voyez
voyez encore une petite chose qui me
trotte derrière la tête et qui me
chagrine pourquoi êtes vous venu répéter
ici on a tout simplement parce que je
désirais connaître l'opinion de mon ami
sinclair sur ma pièce aux deux pourquoi
ici à rambouillet leur ai quand même été
plus simple de vous réunir tous à paris
claire était grippée grippé bas vous
avez été grippé monsieur non le genre
ben oui un petit peu oui oui allez votre
médicament monsieur merci non non ne
buvait pas pourquoi dont il ya tellement
de similitudes entre ma pièce est ce que
nous vivons non je l'appris nous voyons
voyons voyons voir mon ami mais vous
dites vous divaguez boyon non moi je ne
suis pas superstitieux
et puis d'ailleurs on n'oserait pas
m'ont posé devant la commissaire de
police qui soit commissaire marc tout ça
je vous y autorise mon cher m
vous voyez je ne suis pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]